henry cavill x' work on Netflix's The
Witcher is fantastic but the series
supporting cast members are memorable to
chief among them Lars Mikkelsen who
plays the conflicted illusionist Strega
Bor here's why this guy looks so
familiar though he's currently earning
rave reviews for portraying a conniving
dark wizard with a piercing intellect
The Witcher is hardly Lars Mickelson's
first go at Breaking Bad on the small
screen as it happens the actor has had a
pretty great run playing scheming
intellectual sorts in movies and TV
shows over the years as such we'd wager
that many of you who are certain you've
seen Strega Bors face before just might
be familiar with the genius level
blackmailing baddie Charles Augustus
Magnussen one of the most devious
villains to ever face off against Holmes
and Watson in the BBC's pitch-perfect
Sir Arthur Conan Doyle adaptation
Sherlock you just know things how does
that work I just allow fear that so to
your face I'd like to punch it wait a
minute Mickelson appeared in the episode
his last valve which found Holmes and
Watson on the hunt for a collection of
deeply personal letters which were being
used as blackmail against lady Elisabeth
Smallwood their search set Holmes and
Watson on a collision course with
Mickelson's duplicitous media mogul a
course that ends with Magnussen
ultimately outwitting Holmes thus
leaving the legendary sleuth no course
of action but to shoot Magnussen in the
head in hopes of saving the lives and
futures of all those who matter to him
house of cards showrunner beau Willimon
was quick to seize on Mickelson's knack
for playing brainy brutal bad guys when
the series was casting a key supporting
role in Netflix's breakout Drama series
if you count yourself as a fan of house
of cards then we're pretty sure a big
fat light bulb just went off in your
head because Mickelson's turn is the
series calculating shamelessly
manipulative Russian leader viktor
petrov remains one of the high points on
a show that saw dramatic peaks and
valleys over its tumultuous 6 season run
of all the memorable supporting players
who came and went over the course of the
series 73 episodes
Mickelson's potent 13 episode arc as
petrov is the one that continues to
stand tallest if only because the
character's presence was so frequently
felt
even when he wasn't on screen if people
don't like the job you're doing they
vote you out of office if they don't
like the job I'm doing then topple
statues blood is spilt chaos takes over
it's hard to imagine that Netflix brass
wasn't keenly aware of Mickelson's
powerful screen presence on house of
cards
and it seems possible that the actors
ability to hold his own against some
serious dramatic heavy hitters on that
series helped secure his casting on The
Witcher if you've never taken a moment
to check in with either house of cards
or Sherlock it's entirely possible you
don't recognise Mickelson's face at all
but even if that's the case the actor's
voice might ring a bell you might
recognize his performance from a certain
galaxy far far away
specifically the Star Wars franchise's
compelling animated series Star Wars
rebels rebels follows the adventures of
a starship crew who bravely stand up to
the Galactic Empire which is busy
traversing the galaxy stamping out the
remnants of the Jedi Order joining a
star-studded cast of talent including
the likes of David O yellow
clancy brown and more Mickelson lent his
voice to the show by stepping into the
boots of the feared imperial leader
Grand Admiral Thrawn who frequently
tormented the ragtag group of rebels
throughout the series Mickelson has a
number of projects in the works to name
just a couple he'll be featured in the
upcoming crime drama the knife thrower
and on the Danish small screen serial
grow which is currently shooting in the
meantime though he's enjoying the raised
profile that comes with a supporting
role on The Witcher check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]